yeah I'm on the way to work I stopped
okay and I get me a coffee one of them
cafe cups you know and I've been pining
for it all morning I mean I've been
pining like a damn forest you know and I
hadn't had any cafe all morning and then
I'm wish you know I know okay when I
head into the studio almost stop I'm
gonna get me that frothy Brown hitter
that that you know that sipper full of
just brackish and I like that coffee
dirty bread you know I'm saying I like I
just a little bit like I just a scoop of
the dang like somebody just scooped some
some of the Mississippi River into a
cafe cup and presented it at me that's
how I like it I like my [ __ ] got a
little bit of sweat in it you know I
like that dirty cup you know I like that
cup of coffee that it might test
positive for a little something bright
you know the kind of stuff if you if you
mailed a couple drops in the ancestries
internet thing or whatever they come
back at you like damn this [ __ ] you know
this shit's got tomato base in it this
stuff got a little bit of caffeine you
know this just 9% Savannah Herron
African I like that coffee I like that
dirty cup but I'm at the place a park I
get out of my vehicle and write as open
the door actually I'm opening the door
and car hits my hits my door boom just
lit it up I mean I didn't know what it
was at first I thought it was like a dam
just like a rhinoceros bro it was loud
and I thought damn where dot Park you
know in Jumanji because I thought oh
just a rhino just knows that door down
but I get out and it is a it's a Toyota
it's a Toyota Camry and a Toyota Camry
that's a popular car usually for a
stepmother a lot of strippers drive on -
you know you'll see a lot of dancers net
night time you know ladies who got those
legs working at night they drive a Camry
sometimes and a lot of the logos have
been stolen off of the back of it and
anyway the guy hit me it was a childís
beautiful [ __ ] hit me dude I mean
this guy and when I saw him but first of
all he comes up give me a hug - arm hug
and I'll say this it did defuse the
situation because I was a little man I
just got a vehicle I've been in an uber
for four months sitting in the just in
little I mean it sitting and usually
there's a couple little chips you know a
little sour cream and onion residue on
the backseat and I've been just sitting
in that in other people's cars for four
months and then finally I got this
vehicle and BAM his beautiful [ __ ]
runs up both arms those already sorry
that's what he said out of the gate he
double-double so sorry me and it
softened my heart a little you know and
this guy we shop we swap names and he
was look I'm all about different
ethnicities and everything I'm all about
beige power but this guy was extremely
Chinese okay this guy was I don't even
know and I look we've all got different
things about us you know I got them
dirty hips I got that des booty you know
if you see me getting onto a short
school bus from the rear
you wouldn't think anything of it and
that's how much DSi got in these sweet
cheeks back here but um but this man
should not have been driving this man
this man was probably seven hundred
percent Chinese he's uh he did not his
eyes were not open and I don't mean that
he also could have been on you don't
want to him antihistamines he would have
tested positive I think for definitely
some heavy claritin because his eyes
were not open and he was and his car had
looked like it had hit maybe hundred
cars I mean everywhere there could be a
little ding or a bumper thing there was
one and his rear view mirror that's what
caught my door and put like a dent in
like the edge of it and everything is
fine it's all good but man that thing it
just kind of rattled my day and here's
what I'm saying is not everybody should
be doing everything
this guy is should not be driving this
guy's not driving this guy is basically
just bouncing around Los Angeles I mean
there's no way he could see stuff I
think he hugged me in hindsight because
he was just trying to get a notion of
where I was at physically so that way he
could direct his voice in my direction
enough of my ranting um I've got a big
announcement to make
and I thank you guys for being here with
me today and let's start off just with
something to make me a little bit
comfortable you know
[Music]
I'm just fill it in my bones
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]
and tell you
just yet and honesty I don't even know
honestly that man but that Chinese
gentleman might not even have had he
might not even have had eyes I mean he
was he may have been the bravest blind
person in the world he may have just
been the damn American ninja site
warrior but uh anyway good to be here
with you today it is Monday August 29th
2019 and we are burrowing into the
future at the same rate we always have
been one second at a time what's going
on a thank you to everybody came out
this weekend Atlanta was so wild in
Atlanta Memphis Louisville and
Birmingham and we got to stop in and see
the King Elvis Presley the house he was
born in and Elvis was born I mean the
house is tiny
I'm not joking if you really if I had if
I had been maybe smoked about half a
pack of Winston's and if you opened up
the back door and the front door out of
his house and I had a little bit of a
cold and I cleared my throat and you
gave me three steps of running momentum
I think I could spit from the through
the front door out the back door of
Elvis Presley to the launch pad and
right when you go in the door there
there's an old lady sitting there and
she's rest and I think I thought she
might have been deceased but she woke up
and she's right there sitting by the bed
where Elvis was Cohn saved a baby
man I tell you almost want to get into
bed and just you know hope for a little
bit of that magic but it was a beautiful
little home you get to see his high
chair he sat in as a little fella and uh
and we had a nice time and that was over
there in Tupelo Mississippi where we
stopped and saw the birthplace of Elvis
Elvis Presley we went to Sun Studios in
Memphis and um just saw where Johnny
Cash had recorded Carl pic Orton
Pinkerton Pinkerton one of them hot
Carla some people call him hot Karl
andand Elvis himself and it was a great
time and so I got an announcement to
make
it's no no no no I mean I guess I don't
if it's an announcement I just so I just
want to tell you what happened so about
a month ago I got a message on social
media from an actor and this man named
Chris Pratt and he is an actor and he
does you know fancy roles and he also
does comedy roles
he's a very you know he's distinguished
in his industry and from everything I'd
heard he had always heard only that he
was a kind man I got a very nice message
from him and it said you know hey man
I'm paraphrasing hey man I think you're
a funny guy I've been a fan for a while
I'm doing a project coming up and I
would like for you to be in it and you
know me with Hollywood I have different
types of thoughts and and you know I've
passed up on some pilots and different
you know sitcom ideas and things that
people have tried to get me into
there's even an animated series coming
out on Netflix that I did that I got
offered a role in I just there's
different things that I just didn't
really tickle my fancy really or even
even rub my fancy at all and um but this
kind of hit me a little bit different
and it was just a direct it was a direct
message from a man who's funny and who
who I've I've found for myself that I
admire even outside of their work and
even though I don't know him I just I
guess it doesn't make any sense then I
guess I just felt like I've always felt
like he was one of the good guys now
next thing you know they had me come in
and meet with a producer and just go
over one of the roles and Jionni who
works here the beautiful little guy you
know that little Christmas ornament I
mean definitely the kind of guy you he
seemed he seemed like the kind of guy
that would hang out of the he just be
kind of laying around the soap dish in a
male bathhouse you know Jionni well he
helped me go over the lines and work on
it and and when I met with one of the
producers and then they offered me the
opportunity to be in the film and so
that's what I'm gonna do I decided that
I'm gonna go do to go do the film you
know I spoke with a lot of other people
that have been in this situation or you
know had this type of offer you know
Sebastian Maniscalco I spoke with him
about it
Coco Diaz we chatted Bryan Callen even
helped me work on the lines to go read
with the producer and and even Chris
D'Elia almost helped me work on the
lines but he had to go do something but
um but yeah so you know I guess I'm
nervous but I'm excited you know I'm
definitely excited and it's like it's
gonna be a movie that people can see and
look I'm really you know I'm excited
about it
but with everything there is a cost and
one of the reasons you know that I'm
you know something that's hurting me
about it that's really getting me inside
of me right now is that I have to
reschedule some tour dates and and I'm
bummed about that you know I'm really
bummed about it
so those dates that I'm gonna have to
reschedule and I'll talk more about it
after our Glasgow Dublin Oslo Stockholm
London Manchester Amsterdam Sayreville
Bethlehem PA Grand Rapids Detroit
Milwaukee and Madison and that's most of
the fall touring you know and it just
it's it really you know I feel sad about
it I mean I'm bummed out you know I've
really been looking forward to doing the
European tour like and I guess I'm just
you know I you know I guess I don't I
don't want you to think that I don't
care you know I thought a lot about this
you know it's been you know the past
month it's been kind of like in limbo
and I've thought a lot about it and and
and I think it also has been presented
to me at a time where where I needed
some break from what's been going on I
haven't been feeling that good to be
honest with you you know I've been
feeling very a lot of stress and I've
been feeling like I've been able to
connect very much what myself I felt
like I haven't been able to connect
sometimes when I've been on some tour
dates and I think some of us just been
exhaustion in and just the fact that
this came about like that that uh mr.
Pratt reached out to me directly and I
didn't have to go through like a lot of
Hollywood hoopla you know I've just put
myself out there and I mean you honestly
man it felt like like I did it my way
and that you know and to get to then go
and be in like a movie where I mean it
sounds really interesting it's supposed
to be about like fighting for the future
and and like kind of like this powerful
sort of I don't know what I can say
about it I don't even know what all the
rules are I don't even know if I'm
really supposed to be talking about it
but I just needed to tell you that that
those dates that are that you have
tickets for you can get a refund or they
will be to be decided they're gonna be
rescheduled soon I just don't know
exactly when yet but I'll be there as
soon as I can I'll find some way to make
it up to the people who are who are
coming out and I don't know what that'll
be yet but I'll find a way and
yeah I don't know man I've honestly just
been scare I've been like I've been a
little stressed about just talking about
that you know because I love Tornai you
know worked so hard to build up people
to come out to see the shows and then
and the now I'm canceling on you you
know we're not cancelling but now I'm
rescheduling on you and and I'm sorry
you know I really am sorry I don't want
you to feel like I'm trading like
Hollywood for you I don't feel that way
there's been a lot of things that would
have taken my time away from my tour
dates or from my podcast that I've said
no to but this just feels like it's
coming at a moment where I need honestly
I need a little bit of a of a break I
have been feeling that good and
sometimes nobody wants to hear about it
when you have you know future tour dates
or this on the docket or this you know
people don't they don't want to hear
that and as an artist or as a
entertainer you get scared to say that
because you don't want people to not
come and support you you know you work
so hard to get people to come be part of
a group and and then now I'm you know
you're letting them down but that's the
choice that I made and and I feel like
that's what you know I just need I just
think having a different experience you
know it's gonna be eight weeks at least
that we're gonna be shooting this thing
and and it's just gonna be crazy like I
can't even imagine what that's gonna be
like but I will make the show up to you
I will be back to do the shows and um
and I hope you forgive me
you know I hope that you forgive me and
uh
in that and then you don't give up on me
yeah you know you know and I plan to
still bring the dark art store I don't
want to I still want people to see this
show you know this might be I think
maybe my the best show I've ever put
together and so I still want people to
see that specifically and you know the
the place you reached out to for your
tickets they will be the place that will
reach out to you for reimbursement or to
reschedule they'll send you information
however they send it and if you have
other questions then you can email
producer at-at Theo von comm or you can
hit the hotline and we'll do our best to
answer whatever we can as well but your
best bet is gonna be to go through the
ticket people so man I'm sorry
I feel really bad but but I feel I mean
I just I came to explain to you fully
how I've been feeling like it in the
past two weeks especially like I feel
like I've just been hit a little bit of
burnout and I haven't felt like myself
even on the even on the podcast episodes
you know I've just felt disconnected I
noticed when my family was visiting that
I felt like I couldn't really relate
with them and I couldn't be the person
that I wanted to be you know I've missed
like being like a little bit more joyous
and stuff my brain feels like it's
always you know how when you're taking a
test sometimes and you have to like you
know you know you know how normally you
go into class right if you were in high
school or few was in remedial you know
whatever or if you [ __ ] just were
born and then got a job when you were
about 18 whatever maybe you didn't do
school but remember school you would
kind of goof around it was relaxing you
could live your life and then on test
day
the thing I hated the most about test
day in school
you said you couldn't have a regular day
of class where you could have fun and
enjoy each other's vibe and feel you
know shoot a thing at [ __ ] little
Rodney brah shoot a little Wang spit
ball dude hit him you know ball him once
ball him twice and then surprise him
with a little nail you know one of those
little long
one-inch little picture nails and just
hit that bastard boy he knows saying
teach him who his stepdad he is and I
missed that was fun the thing about but
on test day you're like damn man we got
to be quiet
you know everybody leaves class right
when they're done with it it just was a
different vibe and that's what things
have felt like for me a little bit the
past few weeks is just like test day so
I think that this opportunity is coming
at at a um at a time when I'm looking
forward to just being able to have
recharge in some ways I really am
and also it's still something that
everybody will get to see you know so
it's like you know I feel like there
will be a neat way to at least see that
I could do that I could be in a movie
screen and then I did it my way man that
we did it our way you know that we just
put ourselves out there and that we
didn't need a bunch of [ __ ] we
didn't need a bunch of you know like
fake PRBS and that I don't know and
here's the crazy thing is man a couple
of weeks before uh mr. Christopher Pratt
before you sent me a message I had a
thought in my head that he might I was
like what if that man sent me a message
about doing up project with
and that's kind of crazy you know so
anyway I'm gonna quit talking about it
I'm really sorry you know it really
really breaks my heart that I'm not
gonna be able to come to some of these
shows right now I will come to them soon
we will have the dates on the books ASAP
and and some people you know some people
said well look just wait till you know
what the dates are before you announce
that I said nos I want to know I want
people to know what's going on so I
still maybe embraer this weekend I will
definitely be in Biloxi
on the 31st but but those other dates
will be TBD and I'll let you know
through social media or here on the
podcast or the place you bought them
from originally we'll send you a link or
code so that you have the first option
to get the new date oh let's go into
some some calls that came in on the
hotline as always the hotline is nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three and if there's something that
you're struggling with or scared about
or something that's going on in your
life as a young man because we get left
in the cold sometimes fellas we don't
you know a lot of times Society and
stuff just wants to look at young women
right now or animals I mean you see I
saw a video the other day 17 pets were
going to summer camp on a bus well what
the [ __ ] man if you're a pet dude every
day summer camp isn't it you get a treat
you get to you know you run around maybe
you go to a little park and you know
bang another pet you never met her at
least get to smell somebody's mud loot
if fighting is something if any the
definition of summer camp boy we should
have this girl Tiffany bronzed she had
us I don't know how she got tits but she
got him you feel me boy
dude she had tits and this is before
people had tits and TIFF had them tits
okay and she I don't know how she got it
into her head but she thought that
that young fellas men you know future
men boys growing boys what we'd love to
get a little whiff off them tease you
feel me
little frickin get a little just uh nose
Huff off them off them little nipple
Tatars boy you know what I'm saying
nem tits and so for 50 Cent's money
going there smelling tits brush you let
you [ __ ] smelling [ __ ] and look I
was so keyed up at the time on tit that
I couldn't tell you what she looked like
I could I don't know if I ever saw her
face or shoulders or legs or arms or
even her lower torso man all I saw TIFF
was them tenth boy and it was 50 cents
to to take a freaking big snout hey boy
get that snout hit off them just them
happy chest huh furs boy grown gang
and if sales were low boy for $0.25
she'd let you smell one bro but I always
saved up 50 cents and got that double
you feel but God dang it was a good time
and we're even talking about oh yeah
pets are getting everything now man
let's take a hot let's take a call from
the hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three
what's up Nasher over in West Virginia
WV in West Virginia I remember here and
uh I was there years ago and they had
some of the largest people and America
in the world I think even the world
largest body people you know obesity
that was a sip of coffee let's go more
brother Nasir call you last night a
little reveal throw about six hours
Wow man thank you brother thank you so
much man I appreciate that all the way
out there and you thought I could get a
bit dated you a funny [ __ ]
really this was really impressed with
your energy man when you came out just
it's like you're all over the [ __ ]
stage didn't they just over but like you
did a little bump or something out there
man
that's the Lord boy I put a couple grams
at a lord in me onward had a quick
question I went to the Early Show in
Louisville to be specific first comedy
show there have been two so I was kind
of curious to know how that show stacked
up against other shows if that makes any
sense like was that a good crowd bad
crowd what makes a good crab what makes
a bad crowd yeah I was just curious to
know everybody seems fairly well behaved
sometimes already a little hell but him
look like a GE dude but yeah man just
curious to know what makes a good and
bad comedy crowd and how that night was
for you gang brother thank you for
coming through man and thanks for
driving that six hours while you know
what makes a good crowd for me it used
to just be that things were gonna be
fine and then at some points this year
it started to be like if you know I've
talked about it on here a few times if
people got outrageous or real you know
people yelling in the audience too much
or somebody just drunk and cat calling
you know one guy threw up his underpants
on stage what oh boy dude if I'm chasing
something out of somebody's Underpants
brother it ain't gonna be no wiener
brother you feel me
I'm chasing something else boy you know
I'm saying a little bit of cool time
when we so that dude that was wild but I
think just a crowd that's ready to enjoy
themselves
you know a crowd it's not like a
football game I mean dude I did a show
in you know when I take my Netflix
special the one that's not there now
there was some lady in Louisiana in New
Orleans yelling defense the whole game
you know people didn't what the [ __ ] was
going on some people had never been to a
comedy show so this lady mad never even
been out the basement you know she may
have been locked up in the UM you know
she might have been off of that damn I
don't even know Elizabeth Smart dance
team or whatever she yeah you know I
this lady seemed like she'd never even
have to show she was facing the other
direction from the show and she was
yelling defense so but what makes a good
show for me is if people like I know
what I'm trying to do you know and I
want the show to go good and I guess
it's just put their trust in me you know
that that I'm gonna that I'm gonna have
that the show is gonna be good but yeah
I think a little bit of engagement is
fine man you know it people having fun
but when people start to just make it
about themselves at a certain point
that's too much for me
dude Ari threw some guy out that [ __ ]
was hilarious yeah I was sitting in my
backstage and his hair I turned they got
a little volume thing on the wall and I
cranked that thing up I said I'm about
to enjoy it here and all he was like
well I think you can leave then but you
know good for him
dude it's tossing somebody out of a
comedy show is a hard thing to learn to
do you know for years you just if
somebody starts yelling you just
sometimes let them go sometimes you lose
the audience um but I like the
Louisville Lucy I mean just good people
man so many nice people came out and I
know I say that a lot about the shows
but that's who it is
you know that's who's a part of this
group and uh
and yeah I'm just it was a blast man we
had a great time we had a great time
what else makes a good show I think me
feeling okay
you know the second show in Louisville
man and the second show in Atlanta
honestly man I didn't want to go back
out you know we did it and it was good
but you know that's why we didn't do any
meet and greets after those two shows I
just can't there's something uh my
stress level has just been through the
roof I think I've just done put too much
on my plate
and so I'm starting to scale back on
some things I'm gonna start doing some
less guest episodes because honestly I
started to get worried about my own
health and well-being and certainly also
my mental health you know I've been you
know a couple weeks ago I was trying to
figure out what was going on with him
while I was feeling so exhausted I
thought maybe my medicine was wrong so I
tried to adjust my medicine and then
that kind of backfired because I started
just having like real scary thoughts and
stuff and and you know I think I've just
been working so much that I haven't been
able to enjoy the fruits of my labor at
all and I also haven't been able to
focus on the things that make me want to
do this in the first place
you know like doing the single mom stuff
finding ways to focus on help another
young men who struggle you know it gets
to the point where you're doing two
episodes a week he throwing king of the
sting and it's and look it's all good
it's all great problems to have but you
know you start to become part of a part
of a syst part of your own system even
if it's a system you start you you made
for yourself so I think just you
learning some time management for myself
will help me be able to get on stage and
give a fond show because the thing that
makes any show the best is when I'm
having a good time too
and that's what I want to Britt be able
to bring to the shows no matter what and
that's another one of the reasons why
with this movie opportunity that came
along that I said yes to it
look financially isn't it's a big loss
for me financially to take this film and
to do this film opportunity I don't even
know how much I'll be in the deal
yeah look they may cut me and put me on
the floor that's the risk I have to take
but I do feel like a higher power and my
life presented this opportunity to me at
a time when personally I had been
struggling and I used to feel more more
I used to be able to share my struggle
and stuff on the podcast and I just I
think it's been so hard for me to even
access my feelings I've just been so
busy you know and it's been hard to
access them in in all walks of life like
when I meet people it's been hard like I
feel like people don't can't tell if I
care or not sometimes and I hate that
you know I used to know when I met
people and I was like trying to express
you know that I care that they knew and
recently I've been really I've just felt
I don't know if you ever put if you put
a little bit of electricity in an animal
you can still pet that animal but damn
it's that softness has a [ __ ] real
bite to it you know and that's what I
feel like I feel like I've had a lot of
electricity in in my fur and uh and I've
been suffering also at a spiritual level
you know I've been suffering at a
spiritual level for myself
so when you know when the guardian of
the galaxy reached out and said just I
mean through the ether and said hey look
I think you are a funny guy like what
you do and I've been a supporter for a
long time and I think there's a neat
opportunity for you it just seemed like
something that almost was like the
healthiest choice that I had to make for
myself so I know it's selfish but I
think I just there's something that I
need right now to have a just I just
needed a little bit of regrouping and
and a little bit of recharging and so
you know it made me look at everything
that I'm doing and made me realize I'll
just have to make some adjustments
because I want to be able to do things
in my life for the long haul you know I
love going out on the stage man I'm glad
you had fun in Louisville and I'm glad
that I surprised you
because I love to get out there and make
people laugh and when you see couples
sitting there and they're laughs and you
know you see somebody come up this guy
came up to me the other night he said
hey man I just got one year sober you
know him and you inspired me man and I
was looking at him and I felt like so
like hat like not happy but just felt
like I just felt so purposeful and I
couldn't even express that to him and I
didn't need to it you know it's it
wasn't about me but I just wanted him to
let him know look man you know if
something makes you feel good man and
then man that makes me feel good you
know and uh and I just I've just had a
lot of electricity in my fur man it's
been hard for me to connect with others
so you know when I'm learning as I go
and I didn't want to like
you know and maybe this will be a lesson
where I just I don't know I mean there's
a cost to everything you know when some
people may want to not come and see the
shows anymore some people may [ __ ] this
guy or you know I don't know but but I
feel like I'm I feel like I'm making a
good choice for myself for my emotional
well-being at this moment and then
secondarily I know that this will be a
project that people will get to see you
know it's and it's going to be something
that's I mean it sounds crazy I don't
know what if I can talk about it or not
but I mean it's just going to be
seemingly bonkers and to think that that
that I would get to do this you know and
I'd have to be out there it's you know
like and it's not a money thing man did
I it's not it's not that at all but but
I hope to be able to make it up to each
person that I'm going to that we'll have
to reschedule the shows I hope that you
know that and with all that said right
now let's go into this advertisement
Dollar Shave Club and I'll tell you this
man people have sold a lot of [ __ ]
but Dollar Shave Club when I first got
it I said huh huh and now dude I used it
today boy I'm freaking that the SC's got
me tight Dollar Shave Club I can't
stress enough the quality of their
products when I first got there razor I
said well what did this thing heavy you
know what does this have I it could have
an allen wrench on the end but no I
think he's neat I it keeps me classy if
you want to look French or something you
got a piece that could handle it
Dollar Shave Club they spent years
developing crafting refining everything
they have everything I used to look feel
and smell my best you name it they have
it and I use it I've been a dollar shave
club member for one and a half years and
that's true and as amazing as their
shave stuff is Dollar Shave Club is way
more than just razors Dollar Shave Club
has you covered head to toe and that
means you can shave anything you want
boy Wow
wouldn't shave your toes though dying
because that skin looks like a damn
crepe sometimes you getting around the
toes your skin has that real pastry look
I wouldn't take a razor near that and
Dollar Shave Club can keep you
automatically stocked up on the products
you use that's what I like about them
right when I'm out ding dong the door is
there and that's a Dollar Shave Club
doorbell and that thing rings and you
know you got fresh blades I never have
to waste time at a store wondering if
I'm what if I what I'm getting is any
good as a Dollar Shave Club member I
know what I'm getting is the highest
quality and right now you can put the
quality of Dollar Shave club's products
to the test their ultimate shave starter
set has basically everything you need
for an amazing shave the executive razor
shave butter prep scrub now you want
that prep scrub boil you get it and
that's a good thing to tempt a lady hey
come on over you know we got this prep
scrub and let's wash each other's junk
before we enjoy it and that post-shave
dude amber come home the products are
regular prices get your ultimate starter
set for just $5 at dollarshaveclub.com
slash Theo
that's Dollar Shave Club comm slash Theo
and support the the products support the
podcast and they got that hitter man
they got that body butter damn what a
shave butter who do sometimes yeah I
[ __ ] put it you almost want to put a
little bit of a little dash of it on a
Cinnabon dollarshaveclub.com slash Theo
support this past weekend speaking of -
if you've had a long day at work or a
tough day at school or what if you work
at school
what if use a janitor Brown what if
using our valedictorian our teacher or
if you're still stuck at the office it's
time to treat yourself to a meal you
deserve on demand excuse me I just a
belched on demand from your favorite
restaurant restaurants come to you with
door - door - connects to your favorite
restaurants in your city so you're not
going to order something from
you know you might order some beautiful
barbecue from Memphis but if you live in
a in Louisville they gonna have to drive
it it's not that it's local not only is
that burger place you love on door -
already but over three hundred and ten
thousand other amazing restaurants are
as well door - connects you with door to
door delivery in over 3300 cities all 50
states and canada order from your local
go twos or choose from your favorite
chains like Chipotle Wendy's chick-fil-a
and the Cheesecake Factory and they say
cheesecake but they got everything in
there dude the menu about freaking
probably 19 pages long though it's heavy
- can't steal those brought so heavy
bran
don't worry about dinner let dinner come
to you boy what's that door - right now
our listeners can get five dollars off
their first order of 15 or more when you
download the door - app and enter promo
code Theo
that's five dollars off your first order
when you download the door - app from
the App Store and enter promo code Theo
again eat local eat what you want get it
brought to you just lay out you can lay
right by the door and open your mouth
and do might even just scoop it right
India
that's promo code t heo for five dollars
off your first order from door -
download the door - app on the App Store
and use promo code Theo let's take
another call here Austin and Logan Ted
Theodore Logan Alston and Logan calling
you from Colorado thank you for calling
boys out there in Colorado and you're
probably on them mom I'm guessing them
them little bears them gummy bears they
got that DSB or whatever homework from
California Florida
and we will listen to your show to pass
the time the long hours on the road and
you have a lot of things going on and
your your shows but what are the ones
that we're really we're really noticing
is living and gratitude and we're just
super grateful to be able to share this
experience with each other and enjoy
across the country and see these amazing
places and all different types of people
and all walks of life and you're right
there with us you know the whole way so
so we just want to say thanks and you're
making us realize you know you're
putting on the forefront of our heads to
live in gratitude to be grateful for
everything that we have and everything
we're able to do gang man I appreciate
that I appreciate that call um thank you
guys man I hope you're traveling safe
out there hope he's wearing your
seatbelts too because that'll get you a
lot of people think you could just not
wear a seatbelt and you know have you at
36 ounce : that'll stop you if you're in
an accident nah I'm brah
that way if that's the case but you just
gonna die and and you gonna smell like
dr. pepper dog you feel me
which actually ain't that bad dude if
somebody's at your wake or something
they walk by the coffin and they get
that hit and they're like damn what is
that boy Mountain don't bro wear your
seatbelt or but also also drink a drink
you know
because I'll be damned if y'all if you
if you are at a funeral and you walk by
that dead body you get that hit of mr.
Pibb bruh you know that'll make some
money just really grant a little you
know one thing that's funny man I've
been struggling with living and
gratitude man and man it's been paint
that's been really painful for me
[Music]
yes um it's one of the things I've
realized that that some just that work
was big too that I just had was doing
too much work man you know I felt
exhausted I felt like the things that I
was doing didn't even matter to me even
though they were exactly what I wanted
to be doing and it was just I was I
don't know man uh I was just uh and and
it was hard for me to be grateful for
things and I quit doing some of my
gratitude lists in the morning and um
and so thank you man for reminding me
because this morning I woke up and did
it you know this morning I woke up and
did one and I woke up and did a
meditation and I woke up and did a
little bit of um you know just hitting
my knees and just the Serenity Prayer
you know because I've just been feeling
even though it's funny even though I've
had more people in my life than ever
I've been feeling almost a little bit
more alone and so but I'm keen on
getting back into things man and thank
you guys for the call and I know
whatever I focus my energy on will grow
bigger in my life but that makes me feel
good that that was it that that that
that that that's been a theme in the
past man gratitude you know that makes
me feel like at one point I was really
really on a good path and I'm okay
everything's fine I just I just got to
read I just got to calibrate a little so
but gang bro you got to be safe out
there dude and get them mr. pip bruh put
that belt on and get them mr. pip dog
you know think about others you don't
want somebody walking past your funeral
and all they get is a head of uh you
know Old Spice your honor ins so gang
brah let's take another call right here
actually you know what let's hit this uh
this patreon right here thank you for
our patreon supporters
this patreon question comes in Jay
Tito Leibowitz which is better the
original Willy Wonka and the Chocolate
Factory or the remake Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory I don't even need to
finish that one the original dude when
you have little Charlie rolls up and
they got for senior citizens Grandpa Joe
in his little harem bra and they all
wearing dirty nightgowns sleeping in one
bed come on boy that's like I mean that
thing is the closest thing we've seen to
Noah's Ark do when all four of them God
look at all Grandpa Joe's nightgown a
[ __ ] is dirty bruh
dude he's off anybody
there'd be more chocolate in a factory
if Grandpa Joe hadn't been snacking on a
couple dude n is crazy we've seen four
senior citizens and dirty Knight gals
all laying there together that [ __ ] is
everything it's erotic in its you know
it's like early UFC almost kind of
there's something wild about it but
right there Tito which is also one of
the best names ever Tito Leibowitz is
that is that one right there the
original dude the original what they did
in the original without all the CGI and
all the magical effects
now that was creativity and here's one
from jammy star would you upload your
consciousness to live on after you die
gang hmm
that's a good question
I don't know my consciousness because
then you just be sitting alive somewhere
in a tank I would let my consciousness
be alive if it could be in like a
wishing well you know like a tank or
people could throw money and in wish I
think that'd be cool because then you
can see their wishes go by and you can
know that people are still hopeful I
think that made me feel pretty excited
but if you just put my consciousness out
like a dam footlocker or something then
I don't care about all that I have you
not want to be in there people just
trying on you know you know the new
Steph Curry the Third's or whatever I
don't give a dang let's take another
call here do this is iam from Chicago
what's up being over there in Chicago
baby Illinois and man that's a beautiful
law beautiful state man dude if you
think about states Brian you think man
we're the good ones that is hard not to
stop thinking whenever you get to
Illinois
oh we just want to thank you for all you
do for single moms and dads but I want
to make sure you know that you've been a
positive force for us married fathers to
I married my college sweetheart and we
have six kids who are 10 years apart so
[Music]
dude and is continued sexual that's what
that's called when you have six kids 10
years apart that means you guys
continued to have sex boy that's
continued sexual and that's brave I feel
like
a lot of couples they have sex you know
for two years three years get the kids
and then they retreat to their neutral
corners you know and you know masturbate
in a shower or something or sneak off
every now and then to rush or something
but if you're doing continued sexual
bullying over ten years let me give you
that and you think that's clapping no
that's you still smacking her let the
let my neighbor loose brother let him
hang outside of your window get let's
hear more having teenagers and young
adults is really hard in today's world
it's oh hell yeah dude
I've been to 7-eleven there's always
teenagers and young adults hanging
outside of that [ __ ] vaping and just
look you know doing [ __ ] gang
homework
full social media and Instagram and
snapchat and there isn't a whole lot
that my kids want to talk to me about
what I've come to really enjoy is the
common bond that your podcast allows us
to talk and laugh about during the week
they all listen to it we all enjoy it
and it really is a common bond for us
growing up in the 70s the common bond
with my dad with sports and my kids
aren't into sports there's oh man it's
got to be a little hectic sometimes that
the kids aren't into sports and you are
that's got to be tough and then you got
to adapt to if you're the father you
have to adapt you know let's hear a
little more you call thanks their
interests are all over the place
Computers music photography art so I
feel very fortunate to have your weekly
podcast to talk to them about around the
dinner table I also love all the
positive messages that you weave into
your funny stories I think that
sometimes gets lost in everybody
laughing around the table but we all
come to recognize it and love the very
positive messages that you have around
gratitude and life in generals so thank
you and just to make my kids cringe if
they hear this gang gang thank dang boy
dad hit him with that good that's what
I'm talking about Papa daddy sneaking in
Brian that's examen move wrong dude if
you hitting your kids with a gay guy
that's like when your son's about to get
a little better night you know that
significant other you feel me and you
sneak in and put you know massaged his
shoulders right before he puts on that
condom you're filming that's beautiful
brother man Wow Wow bro your pal do you
should be in a museum if you've been
doing continued sexual with your lady
over a decade right you're probably in
the one you're probably in the two
percent of Americans that are doing that
most guys they bother wife that machine
even someone get that cheap when the
gas-powered one with that you know with
that electric hitter on the front and
that's it
they never you know they Bay they see
their wife at mealtime and that's it and
like the kids graduations otherwise
every now and then she just puts an
empty gas can outside of a room door and
let you know that uh that she is doing
okay um no look I'm glad that uh
I'm glad did you guys listen man I think
it's interesting because I get little
pieces of like family and I get little
pieces of you know one of the reasons
why I even let the voicemail go all the
way when I was listening was because I
wanted to just hear a dad's voice you
know I made that thought in my head real
fast my I said okay well I appreciate
the guy's message and I can talk about
it now and then my head said well you
know this is a father's voice so why
don't you just listen to it because you
don't get that all the time and and so
thanks man I get to live vicariously
through you know images of you guys's
lives that I don't get him own life and
so you know thinking about what my
father how he would describe me or what
my interests were you know when hearing
somebody that cares this you know that
much about their kids you know you try
to describe a couple other different
interests and not just say you know that
they're all over the place you you know
you cared enough to a extrapolate on
what they what they like to do you know
it's cool it makes me wonder how my dad
would be or what he would say or what he
would do or you know or if he and I
would bond over listening to some you
know some some guy some some Muppet
who's just rattling on every week but
thank you man I appreciate that sweet of
you to call and uh and it's nice that
you still care enough I think that
that's a challenge these days probably
is just continuing to find ways to
relate to your kids and not be
disappointed if you can't and not give
up if you can't oh I saw this guy last
night feeding his kids food and the kids
were dressed like they're at this fancy
sushi place they're not even paying
attention he's got two kids both I'm
wearing white shirts they looked kind of
like a little bit of like maybe Latino
or Latino Hebrew but like fancy fancy
Latino not like me Connell I'm talking
about like you know like Pablo Escobar's
little boys you know they're both
wearing collared shirts they the
as over there picking his teeth with
something probably the bone of a poor
person you know and and the kids remind
me of the Menendez boys I said aw damn
you know sashimi today you know such see
me today but uh and probably murder
tomorrow this boy yeah I could just see
in 15 years that these boys was he
probably to be doing crime against their
own family they had that Menendez
brothers vibe to them so but yeah that's
beautiful man you got a nice family you
got spend time together and do stuff I
could imagine that people's junk is all
over and probably you got six kids dude
that's 12 chances to slip on a roller
skate bro when you just in the middle of
the night trying to go get a little
glass of milk or something wrong you
know maybe a little pop-tart or
something without the frosting on it I
like I'm plain people look at me weird I
do so you know and I guess I'm just
happy that I'm not tearing families
apart you know I guess I have I'm glad I
haven't had to testify in like one of
those judge Judy's or something you know
or or anything like that but but thanks
for calling me and I really appreciate
it and and at some point you and your
family will be able to go see this movie
man you know I guess I mean I'm really
scared about it you know it's a lot of
risk like just not knowing like what
exactly is gonna happen or you know how
it will all go down but I'm just trying
to be confident about it and hopeful
about it but that would be something
funny though that you guys could go see
me and laugh at that
I hope I'm gonna try to best my best to
make you know make the the guy that I'm
you know uh you know being in the movie
just like a good guy and make him you
know and just represent us as good as I
can man and represent tpw I got this new
Rat King hitter actually as well we got
some new merchandise coming out this
weekend
but thank you guys man I'm getting my
brains getting a little bit of shook
right now you know and I want to
apologize again for having to adjust the
dates and those are to be decided and
and you'll be emailed about a mom but
you know I hope that you know you'd be
patient with me and let me get back to
you and and bring you a good show and
the best show you know I think there's I
think that I think that if I can just
get some of the stress out of my system
then I'll be back into a better place I
mean my life's changed so much in the
past year it's been hard man it's been
beautiful and awesome but uh but there's
a cost like for everything it's like you
know I didn't realize that I was just
stacking a lot I just uh just you know
just been a lot of stress and not even
realizing it man I didn't realize what
uh how intense it is and how much just
how much electricity's gotten in my fur
really I know I keep saying that but
that's just how I feel I feel like if I
was at a petting zoo man I would say
look we this animals got to be in the
back for a couple weeks because he uh
we've been getting complaints you know
we been getting complaints but I want to
go longer but but I just feel I don't
guess I feel a little bit ashamed of
myself too that I'm cancelling the dates
or that I'm rescheduling them so um but
but I'll be back I'll be there we'll
figure it out
you know we figured out a lot bigger
things than this after you and thank you
guys for your patience thank you guys
for your for calling in and and and for
the calls as always on the hotline nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three we'll get into some deeper stuff
next time when I just have my wits a
little bit thicker and
and that's it I'll tell you guys more as
I know more and and that's it man
you guys be good to yourselves and
thanks for being good to me over over
these past few weeks man I've just been
a man I just been like a just like a
rattle
you know just no snake and all rattle
baby
[Music]
I'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could I be so far from my
home and my mind is somewhere else but
when I founded our patch up where it's
been grown now I'm just floating on the
breeze and I feel hopeful and like these
leaves that must be cornerstone oh but
when I reach that round I'll share this
peace of mind I can defeat it in my
thought it's gonna take
a little town for me to set that parking
brake myself
me
[Music]
found of strong I was
moving way too fast on the runaway train
with the handle of matter in these wills
that are been robbed no they want so
this template damn there
[Music]
to make sense a word I came
if you call my name
[Music]
ah
[Applause]